وحديثنا اكثر عن تفاصيل عمليه يا دكتور
ومبارك مره جديده
على هذه الاستضافه صباح الخير على الجميع
في الحقيقه كان لدينا الطفله من الامارات
العربيه المتحده وكانت تعاني من فشلا في
القلب اا فتم قبولها في مستشفى الملك فيصل
التخصص بالرياض وتم نقلها بالاخلاء الطبي
لكي تحضر بالمتابعه الطبيه ومحاوله تقديم
العلاج اللازم لها لما تعاني منهم المشكله
في القلب همم
كمرحله همم الانتقاليه تم وضعها في
البدايه على مضخه القلب الصناعي لمده
تقارب للشهرين حتى يتوفر المتبرع للقلب من
اماره دبي
انتقال الفريق الطبي متكامل عن طريق
الاخلاق الطبي الى الامارات وتم الاتصال
العضو من المتبرع به وتم نقله مباشره مره
اخرى الى الرياض وتم زراعته في الطفله همم
بعد ذلك كانت العلميه ولله الحمد مرت
في من نجاح الى نجاح واستقرت حاله الطفله
بشكل كبير جدا وبعد مضي شهر ونص تقريبا من
اجراء العمليه تم خروجها الى البيت بصحه
جيده معدويها ومع اهلها وهي الان في
المنزل ولله الحمد من قرابه اسبوعين
ووضعها جدا مستقر وتحت متابع اسبوعيه من
الفريق الطبي المعالج
في وقت قياسي في اقل من 24 ساعه انتقل
الفريق الطبي الى دمي الى دبي حامل القلب
الى الشمس في الرياض تم زراعته هناك ما هي
ابرز التحديات التي واجهتكم دكتور في هذه
الزراعه
طبعا هناك تحديات كبيره فاولا من ناحيه ان
العضو المزروع تم نقله من دوله اخرى فهذا
يعني لابد بوجود
التنظيمات لوجستيه كبيره
فتم التنسيق في البدايه بين مركز زراعه
الاعضاء في المملكه العربيه السعوديه
ومركز زراعه الاعضاء في الامارات العربيه
المتحده همم حينما تم ايجاد هذا العضو من
المتبرع به فتم انتقال الفريق الطبي عن
طريق طائرات الاخلاء الطبي التابعه لوزاره
الدفاع السعوديه
انتقلت الى اماره دبي او تم معاينه همم
القلب من المتبرع به وتم الاتفاق على انهم
مناسب للنقل فثم ما تم- اتصاله والعوده به
مباشره بحيث ان الساعات الساعات قليله جدا
التي لابد ان يتم فيها زراعه القلب
فهذه التحديات من عمليه التنسيق الدولي
ومع طائرات الاخلاق طبي تحضير الكوادر
الطبيه المؤهله لاعداد الغرف العمليات همم
لكي يتم زراعه العضو بشكل سريع لابد من
تجهيزها وعمليه التنسيق الكبيره فهذه
تعتبر تحديات كبيره لا تتم لو لا توفر
البنيه التحتيه والكوادر الطبيه المؤهله
والخدمات
اللوجستيه من الطيران والتعاون الدولي بين
السعوديه والامارات الشقيقتين